Коли їдеш на електробайку, де не треба крутити педалей,
витрачати кошти на пальне, це просто сів і поїхав.
Мене звати Данило Тонкопій, засновник компанії Delfast.
Наша команда розробила електровелосипед,
який може проїхати найдовшу у світі відстань
на одному заряді батареї.
[Зелена експедиція
Ukraїner спільно з greencubator]
[Наддніпрянщина]
[Київ]
Це — наш електробайк.
Зараз він заряджається.
Підключено.
Заряджається він від звичайної розетки 220 вольт.
Це модель Top.
Одна з перших наших моделей.
Вона швидкісна.
Її швидкість... Вона швидкісна. Її швидкість....
Прошу вибачення, я приїхав з Казахстану,
тому я не дуже досконально знаю українську мову.
Але ця модель швидкісна.
[До яких міст України можна доїхати на одному заряді акумулятора електровелосипеда Delfast Top з Києва?]
Її швидкість — 80 кілометрів на годину.
Це модель Top, і на її базі була розроблена модель Top Cop.
Поліцейська модифікація для Сполучених Штатів Америки.
Вона має кофри блакитні та червоні мигалки, сирену
і кріплення для вінчестера для поліцейських.
Ми вже продаємо наші байки поліції Мексики.
Поліція Сполучених Штатів Америки тестує зараз нашу Top Cop модель.
Тобто на базі моделі Top ми створили Top Cop.
Ну що, поїдемо?
Delfast — це спочатку була кур'єрська компанія.
Була проблема.
Майже всі електровелосипеди, які є на світовому ринку,
мають пробіг менш ніж 40 кілометрів на одному заряді батареї.
Наші кур'єри проїжджають 100-150
або й більше кілометрів на день.
Вони не можуть заряджатися протягом дня.
Тому ми були вимушені розробити свій власний електробайк.
Мене звати Гончаров Сергій, я головний інженер компанії Delfаst Bikes.
Ми знаходимося в майстерні компанії Delfast, кур'єрської служби.
Тут наочно можна бачити всі наші байки:
як вони починалися, як вони жили і як розвивалися.
Власне, ця майстерня наочно одна з трьох.
Тут, до речі, дуже добре видно що взагалі таке електробайк.
Фактично це батарейка, електромотор і контролер,
який керує електромотором.
Це модель Prime, як я вже казав, тут є бортовий комп'ютер.
Він показує швидкість, рівень заряду, скільки він проїхав,
скільки він може проїхати і подібне.
Ми спробували продавати наші електробайки.
Ми вийшли на Kickstarter — це американська платформа
для збору коштів, як Спільнокошт.
І побачили, що американські та європейські світові
покупці зацікавлені нашим продуктом — нашим байком.
Вони купують його. Вони платять 4-5 тисяч доларів за кожен байк.
Нам, українській компанії.
Ми зрозуміли, що в світі є попит на такий продукт,
на такий електробайк, електровелосипед,
який має дуже великий пробіг.
Переваги електро[транспорту] стосовно бензинного
транспорту зрозумілі — вартість експлуатації.
Тобто електротранспорт набагато дешевший у володінні.
[Електровелосипед і легкий мотоцикл: у чому різниця?]
Він набагато простіший в обслуговуванні.
Тобто моторист тут не потрібен.
Це про кількість людей, які обслуговують електротранспорт.
І системний алгоритм дуже простий.
Що дає електротранспорт?
Тобто є така система, навіть найпростіші електровелосипеди,
які мають таку систему, — pedal assist.
Це система, яка включає електромотор для того,
щоб допомагати людині їхати.
Тобто людина завжди крутить педалі з однаковим зусиллям.
В горку, під горку, як завгодно.
Не важливо вік людини. І завжди буде крутити однаково.
Виникає так званий ефект коваля.
Тобто всі знають, шо коваль може тридцять років
махати молотом, і бути худим.
Тому, що людина просто до навантажень звикає.
І от ці електровелосипеди дали можливість
використовувати їх професійно.
Після сотень випробувальних експериментів, помилок,
якихось граблів, ми зробили велосипед,
який міг проїхати 380 кілометрів на одному заряді батареї.
Ми вирішили спробувати продати цей байк.
І щоб мати докази, що він проїжджає 380 кілометрів,
ми поїхали по Житомирській трасі.
Приїхали в Рівне — залишалося 20 чи 25% батареї.
Ми доїхали до Дубно. Все зафіксували на камери, на GoPro.
Та опублікували на YouTube,
щоб показати всьому світу, що наш байк проїжджає 380 кілометрів.
Це було в десять разів швидше, ніж інші байки в світі.
Це був дійсно прорив.
Після цього рекорду, коли ми проїхали 380 кілометрів,
світові видання почали публікувати:
«Електробайк з України проїжджає більше, ніж Tesla».
Тому що Tesla 3 має пробіг лише 340 кілометрів.
а ми проїжджаємо 380 кілометрів.
Це був фурор! Про нас тоді всі говорили.
Чому електричні велосипеди, хоча їм сто років,
умовно кажучи, з'явилися тільки зараз?
Бо без контролю — постійного контролю —
за струмом, за зарядкою, розрядкою,
експлуатувати цей транспорт неможливо.
Тому спочатку з'явилися комп'ютери, потім з'явилися
дуже маленькі комп'ютери — смартфони,
а потім уже з'явився ефективний електротранспорт.
По суті це смартфон на колесах,
завданням якого є їздити.
Ефективно і безпечно їздити.
Тому ці електровелосипеди є по суті високотехнологічними.
Хоча й досить простими.
Таке часто буває: якийсь винахід високотехнологічний
потім виглядає дуже простим.
Це якраз про електровелосипеди.
Мій тато Михайло Сансонович Тонкопій —
автор цієї книги та ще понад трьохсот книг й робіт.
[російською] «Екологія та економіка природокористування».
Я виріс в Казахстані, в Алмати.
Мій тато — професор екології.
Тобто я з дитинства ріс в екологічній проблематиці.
Я розумів, чому саме повітря в містах забруднюється
та що треба робити, щоб воно ставало чистішим.
Я виріс з малих років
з розумінням того, що ми відповідальні за те, що ми робимо.
[Порівняння викидів вуглекислого газу (або СО2)
від легкого мотоцикла та електровелосипеда]
В порівнянні зі звичайними мопедами,
які використовують пальне, бензин або дизель,
[електровелосипед] не забруднює повітря.
Не потребує пального та зберігає кошти.
Я певен, що Україна має дуже великий потенціал
до світових технологічних проєктів.
В Україні дуже багато талановитих інженерів,
технологічних фахівців, людей,
які мають щось робити власноруч.
Але ці інженери не завжди мають продавати свій продукт.
Тому ми маємо навчитися продавати.
Не тільки розробляти, а ще й продавати світові.
Тоді Україна зможе заробити купу грошей з усього світу.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерки
Каріна Пілюгіна, Наталія Вишинська]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Інтерв'юерка
Оксана Кузема]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб, Олександр Портян]
[Ukraїner спільно з greencubator]
[Створено за підтримки проєкту «Кліматичні Інноваційні Ваучери»,
що фінансується ЄБРР та ЄС]